hi I'm penny loyal member of parliament
from sample and also the founder and
president of the Social Innovation I've
received a question from mr. thumbprint
course people must move dance and his
question is do you believe in formal mr.
sectors are given enough attention from
investors and banks how can we promote
to this practice Oh in the space of the
importance exit itself to see a lot of
microcon prettiest many of them are tend
to be females because they are obvious
biweekly and because of that your focus
is really on building the micro
businesses rather than talking about it
marketing it and you know bringing it to
state where the singing what
multinational companies do it the only
way that we can give enough recognition
today's experience is really much damage
some of the criteria that we measure to
measure the success of businesses and
that means to not just look at how much
progress they're making on the daily
weekly monthly or even the early basis
but do you get social impacts that
you're also creating on the community on
your family of course themselves take
the agents of change obviously that
requires a lot of rethinking on policy
frameworks as well as investor kpi's
shareholders Babu kpi's who will have to
be augmented or and maybe even Stock
Exchange kpi's how to measure the
success of a company how do we rate and
random companies would have to be really
this is obviously a future sighs that
we've got to start somewhere and look at
double bottom time it's the way home